[Music]
Joe how's morale this morning there was
great I got dry we're doing okay uh tell
me what happened last night so how does
the ball is the ball designed to be in
your hands with the game on the line
last night uh last night it was uh it
was just design for me to set a pick and
kind of get out of there and they both
went to George Hill and he he made the
right play pass it to me and I just
tried to do whatever I could that keep
it up a bucket yeah but your eye so Joe
why would they let you get the game
winner off you got 20,000 points Joe its
players or the game plan is we got by
moose a rodney was in the hedge I'll
pick a rose so he was hedging so I just
got out of there quick which kind of
letting you out over how do you explain
your career seven-time all-star my
career obviously from he managed a great
I played in some great places I've met a
lot of great people I've enjoyed it I've
enjoyed it you have a 20,000 points
seven-time all-star and I mentioned this
is your like an overnight sensation here
Joe after 16 years in the league yeah I
know it seems like every year I'm
proving myself even even the years ago
at 11 and then the years out lesson 11
you seem like every other had to prove
that I can steal place for what every
who came up with I so Joe uh who came
over there I don't know how's you get my
mouth here do you view that as a
compliment uh I don't know I mean it
doesn't bother me you know I just try to
go out there and do whatever I can help
my team game wins so the nicknames that
get a thrust upon me I don't bother them
you consider yourself old no I don't I
don't I feel great you know 35 years old
I feel great I'm playing to a basketball
so that's what matters
well you were in the Phoenix system
there for a while right
that was a lot of fun a lot of fun knows
the first year we got Nash the first
year we got Master severely one thing 62
games and that was only your player and
after that contain kind of got broke up
but uh it was a lot of fun what did you
think of Nash when you first started
playing with it then I just I already I
really remembers his work ethic how he
was always the first one at practice
always doing drills by itself and and
virtually pretty much the last one the
lead and you know it's just work ethic
was incredible and that's why he was a
two-time MVP and uh you know I admired
that did you play against Jordan when he
was with the Wizards haha the out player
use MJ when he first came back through
was I was a false cricketer and what
happened here what happened man we beat
him but I was kind of start up the whole
game because I hadn't caught I think I
had the garden even Paul kids was
talking talking jump back and forth the
whole game I'm thinking to myself Paul
just kind of chill out you can see what
I got no as a rookie as a rookie man I
enjoyed that moment and I still I still
watch that to this day what do you
remember about that here you are rookie
with the Celtics and Mike comes to town
granite ease with the Wizards and you
know Pierce who's not guarding him is
giving him you know back and forth but
what do you remember most about that I
remember uh Matt I just remember trying
to play with I was there I remember
being at a tea game and I just wanted to
play well against it I knew I was was a
little bit as probable or was it screwed
up by these great crappy at any age I
think she's probably 38 but uh man he
was granting he had he probably had
about what 27 2014 and you honey thought
you did a good job on him right I
thought of giving we got to win this
crowd
he's a Joe Johnson I so Joe the Utah
Jazz hit the game-winner against the
Clippers last night toughest guy you've
ever covered is who the toughest guy
I've ever covered uh may you know what
but when I was my first game of the
league the toughest guys with me to God
as we was uh
Cuttino Mobley for whatever reason I
don't know if it was because he was just
wiry and you know date in Houston they
play that isolation basketball then took
me a while to really that's it but he
gave me problems my first few years of
Glee and plus being left-handed that's
what it was yeah there's a being a lefty
very crafty very strong cuz she was
great the isolation the arrows toe
I heard you do yoga all the time to any
of your teammates do yoga with you yeah
I got about I got about six of the guys
on the team going in cool clothes and
stones Oh No
yeah I know I know it's bad but hey we
enjoyed man you know what I got into
yoga probably about six years ago
probably about my last couple years in
Atlanta I was having a lot of uh
tendinitis problem with my knees tight
hamstrings Achilles and uh I tried it
one time with my trainer and his wife
and I fell in love with it is there a
better shooter on the team than you uh
yeah I was a pretty good shooter I think
that's what but that's what makes us a
pretty good team because we just face it
out and then you can't you don't want to
leave you know some of the guys that we
have I don't look very great shooting so
what do you think I'm up on the best
shooter but I'm one Oh what do you think
in Hayward's haircut I like it we feel
like he like a model dummy
he ain't got quite a partner's hair
they're like does he put gel on his hair
before a game Joe I'm not basil
obviously last night on the plane he had
a baby you ty was playing cards of each
boy are two of the guys who play cards
and uh I was looking at is here I wonder
I stayed up
and find these things out uh how many
more years you can play I have no idea I
put a limitation on it
yeah after year you know you try to keep
going long as my body feels great I keep
going well Joe congratulations on
another game-winning jumper there and
good luck against the Clippers coming up
on Friday 9:00 tomorrow night that's Joe
Johnson I saw Joe the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience